françoise herbe f3 strasbourg
la porte de brandebourg à berlin la nuit
dernière des centaines de personnes se
sont massées à l'ouest devant le centre
historique de la ville et attendre qu'un
passage soient ouverts ici dans le mur
toutes les télévisions sont présentes
car la rumeur court insistante depuis
plusieurs heures cela fait 28 ans que la
porte de brandebourg symbole de la ville
est fermée personne ne veut manquer les
travaux de percement du mur qui vit à
ces endroits ces dernières heures cette
nouvelle brèche vers la liberté se fera
sans doute demain
journée ordinaire à une chute est ville
frontalière de la république fédérale
allemande à quelques kilomètres de
magdebourg en rda il n'est pas encore 9
heures des allemands de l'est affluent
par milliers tous les matins et cela
malgré la reprise du travail en début de
semaine la plupart sont arrivés à 7
heures ce matin par un train spécial les
files d'attentes devant la poste les
banques et l'hôtel de ville pour obtenir
la prime d'accueil de 100 marques sont
impressionnantes 6 millions ici ont été
distribués pour le seul week-end dernier
et ce n'est pas fini
qu allez vous acheter je vais acheter
des choses pour les enfants des cadeaux
pour noël et des mandarines aussi
tout est là tout est en vente libre il
va falloir mon travail et pour cela
j'ai regardé mais il ya tellement de
choses que je n'arrive pas à choisir les
commerçants le sont ravis ils sont
nombreux à proposer des réductions aux
touristes est allemand ici comme partout
à la frontière on s'attend pour cette
fin de semaine un rush encore plus
important que celui du week-end dernier
un seul problème pour les citoyens
est-allemands leur voiture ton très
souvent en panne le moteur à deux temps
souffre en effet sur les routes ouest
allemande mais on trouve plus aucune
pièce détachée de travail ou de barbour
dans toute l'allemagne fédérale